hey youtubers it's Charlie so surprise
surprise a bunch of preview images for
Batman V Superman just dropped so
there's gonna be a breakdown of that
along with a list of Batman's greatest
loves because it kind of looks like
something might be going on between him
and Wonder Woman but I don't think the
movies gonna go there if there's
anything going on between Batman and
Wonder Woman in the movie I would say
that they're just gonna have sexual
chemistry I'm not expecting it to do
that cliche thing where it's like the
two dudes fight over the one woman but
to add some context as to why Wonder
Woman would know Batman but not know
Superman we've learned from the Wonder
Woman movie like with the way they've
been planning that that it's going to
take place in the 1920s so she's been on
earth for a long time so she would have
just had more time to get to know
everyone she's gonna be something of a
diplomat in the movie the government
itself plays a big role so so it gives
you an idea for why Wonder Woman is
necessary if she's such a great
politician Batman of course is
ubiquitous in the DC Universe he's the
world's greatest detective meaning that
he goes all over the world so of course
they'll probably run into each other at
some point as for what their history is
we don't know yet but that you know
Batman looks so grumpy and old it looks
like things didn't end well just looking
at the tone of Zack Snyder's films in
general and what's going on with these
characters that we've seen in the
trailer so far it gives me this very
watchman type vibe like some of the
themes from Watchmen with more
mainstream DC characters I think the
departure for this film though is the
addition of Superman and that he
represents hope he's not like dr.
Manhattan where he's become so powerful
he just loses all connection with
humanity if you are a big fan of the
Watchmen comics though that's
essentially what dr. Manhattan is meant
to represent it's like Alan Moore's dark
version of what would really happen if
we had a Superman on our planet you just
become so godlike that he would stop
caring about humans the difference is
that Superman says that his family is
simple like the core operating belief of
his house is hope and he didn't start
out a human like dr. Manhattan did so
there was no humanity to lose to begin
with if you've been reading the comics
recently though Superman's going through
some huge changes they depowered him big
time and they broke him and Wonder Woman
up they've been going out for a long
time in the comics during the new 52
which I am a hundred percent on board
with even if some of the new Superman
stories don't work out I just I like
them trying new things with these
characters speaking of which
Lex Luthor's hair look at this hair
he looks like he's in a grunge band the
movie is spinning his character as a
tech billionaire just because in today's
world tech is such a booming industry
that's where most young billionaires
rise from regardless of what your
opinion of Jesse Eisenberg is I think he
tried to bring a more complicated
version of the character to the screen
you know typically the more comical
versions like Kevin Spacey a little more
comical all the way back to Gene Hackman
those are great characters they had
great performances but those versions of
Lex Luthor were just a little more over
the top Zack Snyder a little more down
and dirty so we're not gonna see
characters like that in the movie he
doesn't do slapstick comedy there are a
lot of rumors about what Lex Luthor is
gonna be doing in the film but he is a
Superman villain so even if he's morally
grave for most of the film he will
probably walk away being one of the
villains you will probably walk out of
the theater saying yeah he was one of
the bad guys if not the most obvious bad
guy in a film like this where they're
trying to weave in a lot of metaphors
about the role of superheroes in modern
society there's gonna be like the
monster villain like the one that they
punch the out of and then there's
gonna be the more ambiguous villains
which is probably the category that Lex
Luthor is gonna fall into a better term
to use will be antagonists because you
know you have you a Batman V Superman
which makes it sound like a court case I
know that makes it sound like a two-hour
episode of Law & Order
but I'm sure there's some of you that
actually really do like Law & Order even
even though I can't stand it given what
we know about Batman that like the level
of distrust that he has for everyone you
can see how he might view Superman given
the battle he just had with all the
Kryptonians half of the world's gonna
love Superman they'll worship him like a
god that that's why these symbols are on
these these soldiers arms the other half
will want to burn him at the stake and
so you can see how people like Lex
Luthor would try to swing people one way
or another try to influence Congress
with lobbyists try to influence people
like Batman by making them more paranoid
Wonder Woman the diplomat is probably
going to be the common ground she'll
probably be the one to slap both of them
to their senses and say you know stop
fighting there's a bigger threat
and when I say bigger threat I'm talking
about like the monster villain the one
that they have to punch the out of
there really isn't enough information to
speculate on that so I want to go too
deep into who the actual villain might
be there's rumors that there might be a
doomsday type character but feel free to
speculate in the comments but here's my
big question for you guys is actually
kind of a funny
get given this picture do you think that
anything has been going on or will be
going on between Wonder Woman and Batman
in this movie I know I promise to do a
breakdown of all of Batman's biggest
relationships but DC Comics very big
universe so he has gone out with a lot
of women he is a man in the best
possible way but here are some of the
biggest characters that he's had
relationships with the biggest ones
obviously Selina Kyle Talia al Ghul who
he has a child with Vicki Vale Pamela
Isley Wonder Woman Black Canary Zatanna
Vesper Fairchild and even Lois Lane but
that was only in the new Batman
adventures whenever it crossed over was
Superman the animated series Superman
yeah he got really pissed about that it
didn't last or anything blow us broke up
with Bruce when she found out he was
Batman one of the greatest changes I
think that they've made to Lois Lane in
the movie so far is that she's smart
enough to figure out who Superman is
right away it's not like he walks around
all day at the Daily Planet for years
and years before she figures it out
I feel like that'd be a huge disservice
to any character like if you're able to
fool them by putting a pair of
eyeglasses on like how could you call
yourself a puss or winning journalist if
you were fooled by something so simple
so if that's any indication the way they
treat Lois Lane in this universe
do not worry there's not gonna be like a
crazy amount of shipping or anything in
the movie it's really intended to set
the stage for Justice League like
explain logically why all these big
superheroes need to come together there
has to be a need before the team is
formed so in case you didn't see I
started a giveaway in my flash killer
frost video I'm doing like a Marvel and
a DC giveaway every week so it usually
just starts with like the first Marvel
and the first DC video I post so
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Tyler Gonzales you and a $20
Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info I'll
announce the Marvel winner whenever I
post my spider-man dones video tomorrow
I was actually gonna post that now but
this Batman vs. Superman stuff happened
so I just I wanted to get it out fast if
you're not sure about that just watch
the Captain America video that I just
posted I explained it in that video just
to remind you guys about Comic Con
Batman vs Superman is doing all their
stuff on Saturday not this Saturday but
like the week after that I'll be
recording the panel any footage that
they allow I mean you know if they show
something at Hall H I can't record it
but if they post it online then it is
fine I'll be doing separate Comic Con
preview videos that'll explain like what
the schedules gonna be like what videos
I'm gonna be making all that kind of
stuff so just look out for that starting
tomorrow just since it's been a little
while in case you guys haven't watched
it recently you can click here to watch
the Batman vs Superman trailer again and
you can click here for my killer frost
video that I just did thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow